hola buen día pues tras una jornada
maratoniana como señalaba de más de 15
horas en las que un diputado el diputado
jaime naranjo estuvo leyendo un
documento durante 14 horas para dar
tiempo a que uno de los diputados que
iba a votar a favor de esta acusación y
que estaba en una cuarentena pudiera
alcanzar a llegar al congreso se aprueba
finalmente en la mañana de hoy este esta
acusación constitucional contra piñera
que en la práctica las acusaciones
constitucionales cuando se llevan a cabo
contra ministros suponen que terminen
sus funciones pero al ser el caso del
presidente este no sería el caso el
presidente continuaría en sus funciones
pero tendría una orden de arraigo que le
impediría salir del país y que tendría
una serie de limitaciones
administrativas lo que le queda de
mandato recordemos que sebastián piñera
ceder a su mandato en marzo del próximo
año ahora patricia se espera que este
proceso pase al senado le pregunto que
sigue entonces en la cámara alta
así es en los próximos seis días este
proyecto tiene que ser puesto en la
tabla del senado donde es muy difícil
que alcance los votos necesita ser
aprobado por más de dos tercios es tres
de los 43 senadores que existen 29
necesitan aprobar esta acusación
constitucional y la oposición sólo
cuenta con 24 25 de los votos es muy
difícil que alcancen los 45 votos
restantes que les queda esto haría muy
difícil que la acusación realmente
prosperase pero sí recordar que es la
segunda vez en este mandato que
sebastián piñera enfrenta una acusación
constitucional la vez anterior fue por
las graves violaciones a los derechos
humanos que sucedieron durante el
estallido social del 18 de octubre de